thank you
let me start I want to want to start by
thanking Elaine Elaine thank you so much
we are so grateful for your family
service and sacrifice and we will always
have your back
over the past few years as first lady I
have had the extraordinary privilege of
traveling all across this country and
everywhere I've gone and the people I've
met and the stories I've heard I have
seen the very best of the American
spirit I have seen it in the the
incredible kindness and warmth that
people have shown me and my family
especially our girls I've seen it in in
teachers in a near bankrupt school
district who vowed to keep teaching
without pay I've seen it in people who
become heroes at a moment's notice
diving into harm's way to save others
flying across the country to put out a
fire driving for hours to bail out of
flooded town and I've seen it in our men
and women in uniform and our proud
military families in wounded warriors
who tell me they're not just going to
walk again they're going to run and
they're going to run marathons in the
young man blinded by a bomb in
afghanistan who said simply i'd give my
eyes 100 times again to have the chance
to do what I have done and what I can
still do every day the people i meet
inspire me every day they make me proud
every day they remind me how blessed we
are to live in the greatest nation on
earth
serving as your first lady is an honor
and a privilege but back when we first
came together for years ago I still had
some concerns about this journey we'd
begun while I believed deeply in my
husband's vision for this country and I
was certain he would make an
extraordinary president like any mother
I was worried about what it would mean
for our girls if he got that chance how
would we keep them grounded under the
glare of the national spotlight how
would they feel being uprooted from
their school their friend's in the only
home they'd ever known see our life
before moving to Washington was was
filled with simple joys saturdays at
soccer games sundays at grandma's house
and a date night for barack and me was
either dinner or movie because as an
exhausted mom I couldn't stay awake for
both and the truth is I loved the life
we had built for our girls and I deeply
love the man I had built that life with
and I didn't want that to change if he
became president
Rock just the way he was you see even
back then when Barack was a senator and
a presidential candidate to me he was
still the guy who picked me up for our
dates in a car that was so rusted out I
could actually see the pavement going by
in a hole in the passenger side door he
was the guy whose proudest possession
was a coffee table he'd found in a
dumpster and whose only pair of decent
shoes was a half size too small but see
when when Barack started telling me
about his family see now that's when I
knew I had found a kindred spirit
someone whose values and upbringing were
so much like mine you see Barack and I
were both raised by families who didn't
have much in the way money or material
possessions but who had given us
something far more valuable their
unconditional love their unflinching
sacrifice and the chance to go places
they had never imagined for themselves
my father was a pump operator at the
city water plant and he was diagnosed
with multiple sclerosis when my brother
and I were young and even as a kid I
knew there were plenty of days when he
was in pain and I knew there were plenty
of mornings when it was a struggle for
him to simply get out of bed but every
morning I watched my father wake up with
a smile now grab his Walker prop himself
up against the bathroom sink and slowly
shave and but in his uniform and when he
returned home after a long day's work my
brother and I would would stand at the
top of the stairs of our little
apartment patiently waiting to greet him
watching has he reached down to lift one
leg and then the other to slowly climb
his way into our arms but despite these
challenges my dad hard
ever missed a day of work he and my mom
were determined to give me and my
brother the kind of education they could
only dream up and when my brother and I
finally made it to college nearly all of
our tuition came from student loans and
grants but my dad still had to pay a
tiny portion of that tuition himself and
every semester he was determined to pay
that bill right on time even taking out
loans when he fell short he was so proud
to be sending his kids to college and he
made sure we never missed a registration
deadline because his check was late you
see for my dad that's what it meant to
be a man like like so many of us that
was the measure of his success in life
being able to earn a decent living that
allowed him to support his family and as
I got to know Barack I realized that
even though he had grown up all the way
across the country he'd been brought up
just like me Barack was raised by a
single mom who struggled to pay the
bills and by grandparents who stepped in
when she needed help Barak's grandmother
started out as a secretary at a
community bank and she moved quickly up
the ranks but like so many women she hit
a glass ceiling and for years men no
more qualified than she was men she had
actually trained were promoted up the
ladder ahead of her earning more and
more money while Barak's family
continued to scrape by but day after day
she kept on waking up at dawn to catch
the bus arriving at work before anyone
else giving her best without complaint
or regret and she would often tell
Barack so long as you kids do well bear
that's all that really matters like like
so many American families our families
weren't asking for much
they didn't begrudge anyone else's
success or care that others had much
more than they did in fact they admired
it they simply believed in that
fundamental American promise that even
if you don't start out with much if you
work hard and do what you're supposed to
do you should be able to build a decent
life for yourself in an even better life
for your kids and grandkids that's how
they raised us that's what we learned
from their example we learned about
dignity and decency that how hard you
work matters more than how much you make
that helping others means more than just
getting ahead of yourself we learned
about honesty and integrity that the
truth matters that that you don't take
shortcuts or play by your own set of
rules
doesn't count unless you earn it fair
and square we learned about gratitude
and humility that so many people had a
hand in our success from the teachers
who inspired us to the janitors who kept
our school clean and we were taught to
value everyone's contribution and treat
everyone with respect those are the
values that Barack and I and so many of
you are trying to pass on to our own
children that's who we are and standing
before you four years ago I knew that I
didn't want any of that to change if
Barack became president well today after
so many struggles and triumphs and
moments that have tested my husband in
ways I never could have imagined I have
seen firsthand that being president
doesn't change who you are no it reveals
who you are
I've gotten to see up close and personal
what being president really looks like
and I've seen how the issues that come
across a President's desk are always the
hard ones you know the problems where no
amount of data or numbers will get you
to the right answer the judgment calls
with the stakes are so high and there is
no margin for error and its president
you're going to get all kinds of advice
from all kinds of people but at the end
of the day when it comes time to make
that decision as president all you have
to guide you are your values and your
vision and the life experiences that
make you who you are
so when it comes to rebuilding our
economy Barack is thinking about folks
like my dad and like his grandmother
he's thinking about the pride that comes
from a hard day's work that's why he
signed the lilly Ledbetter Fair Pay Act
to help women get equal pay for equal
work that's why he cut taxes for working
families and small businesses and fought
to get the auto industry back on its
feet
that's how he brought our economy from
the brink of collapse to creating jobs
again jobs you can raise a family on
good jobs right here in the United
States of America
when it comes to the health of our
families Barack refused to listen to all
those folks who told him to leave health
reform for another day another president
he didn't care whether it was the easy
thing to do politically no that's not
how he was raised he cared that it was
the right thing to do
he did it because he believes that here
in America our grandparents should be
able to afford their medicine our kids
should be able to see a doctor when
they're sick and no one in this country
should ever go broke because of an
accident or an illness
and
he believes that women are more than
capable of making our own choices about
our bodies and our health care that's
what
when it comes to giving our kids the
education they deserve Barack knows that
like me and like so many of you he never
could have attended college without
financial aid and believe it or not when
we were first married our combined
monthly student loan bill was actually
higher than our mortgage yeah we were so
young so in love and so in debt and
that's why Barack has fought so hard to
increase student aid and keep interest
rates down because he wants every young
person to fulfill their promise and be
able to attend college without a
mountain of debt so in the end for
Barack these issues aren't political
their personal because Barack knows what
it means when a family struggles he
knows what it means to want something
more for your kids and grandkids Barack
knows the American dream because he's
lived it and he wants everyone in this
country everyone to have the same
opportunity no matter who we are or
where we're from or what we look like or
who we love
and he believes that when you've worked
hard and done well and and walk through
that doorway of opportunity you do not
slam it shut behind you know you reach
back and you give other folks the same
chances that help you succeed
when when people ask me whether being in
the White House has changed my husband I
can honestly say that when it comes to
his character and his convictions and
his heart Barack Obama is still the same
man I fell in love with all those years
ago yeah he's the same man who started
his career by turning down high-paying
jobs and instead working in struggling
neighborhoods where a steel planet shut
down fighting to rebuild those
communities and get folks back to work
because for Barack success isn't about
how much money you make it's about the
difference you make in people's lives
he he
the same man he's the same man when our
girls were first born would anxiously
check their cribs every few minutes to
ensure that they were still breathing
proudly showing them off to everyone we
knew you see that's the man who sits
down with me and our girls for dinner
nearly every night patiently answering
questions about issues in the news
strategizing about middle school
friendships that's the man I see in
those quiet moments late at night
hunched over his desk poring over the
letters people have sent him the letter
from the father struggling to pay his
bills for from the woman dying of cancer
whose insurance company won't cover her
care for from the young people with so
much promise but so few opportunities
and I see the concern in his eyes and I
hear the determination in his voice as
he tells me you won't believe what these
folks are going through Michelle it's
not right we've got to keep working to
fix this we've got so much more to do
see how those stories our collection of
struggles and hopes and dreams I see how
that's what drives Barack Obama every
single day and I didn't think that it
was possible but let me tell you today I
love my husband even more than I did
four years ago even more than I did 23
years ago when we first met let me tell
you why see I love that he has never
forgotten how he started I love that we
can trust Barack to do what he says he's
going to do even when it's hard
especially when it's hard yeah I love
that for Barack there is no such thing
as us and them he doesn't care whether
you're a Democrat a Republican or none
of the above he knows that we all love
our country and he is always ready to
listen a good idea he's always looking
for the very best in everyone he meets
and I love that even in the toughest
moments when we're all sweating it when
when we're worried that the bill won't
pass and it seems like all is lost see
Barack never lets himself get distracted
by the chatter and the lloyds no just
like his grandmother he just keeps
getting up and moving forward with
patience and wisdom and courage and
grace
and he reminds me
he reminds me that we are playing a long
game here and that change is hard and
change is slow and it never happens all
at once but eventually we get there we
always do we get there because of folks
like my dad folks like Barak's
grandmother men and women who said to
themselves I may not have a chance to
fulfill my dreams but maybe my children
will maybe my grandchildren will see so
many of us stand here tonight because of
their sacrifice and longing in steadfast
love because time and again they
swallowed their fears and doubts and did
what was hard so today when the
challenges we face start to seem
overwhelming or even impossible let us
never forget that doing the impossible
is the history of this nation it is who
we are as Americans it is how this
country was built
you
and and if our parents and grandparents
could toil and struggle for us you know
if they could raise beans of steel to
the sky send a man to the moon connect
the world with a touch of a button then
surely we can keep on sacrificing and
building for our own kids and grandkids
right and and if so many brave men and
women could wear our country's uniform
and sacrifice their lives for our most
fundamental rights then surely we can do
our part as citizens of this great
democracy to exercise those rights
surely we can get to the polls on
Election Day and make our voices heard
farmers and blacksmiths could win
independence from an empire if
immigrants could leave behind everything
they knew for better life on our shores
if women could be dragged to jail for
seeking the vote if a generation could
defeat a depression and define greatness
for all time if a young preacher could
lift us to the mountaintop with his
righteous dream and if proud Americans
can be who they are and boldly stand at
the altar with who they love that surely
surely
we can give everyone in this country a
fair chance at that great American dream
in the end in the end more than anything
else that is the story of this country
the story of unwavering hope rounded an
unyielding struggle that is what has
made my story and broad story and and so
many other American stories possible and
let me tell you something I say all of
this tonight not just as first lady no
not just as a wife you see at the end of
the day my most important title is still
mom and chief
my daughters are still the heart of my
heart and the center of my world but let
me tell you today I have none of those
worries from four years ago no not about
whether Barack and I were doing what was
best for our girls because today I know
from experience that if I truly want to
leave a better world for my daughters
and for all of our sons and daughters if
we want to give all of our children a
foundation for their dreams and
opportunities worthy of their promise if
we want to give them that sense of
limitless possibility that believes that
here in America there is always
something better out there if you're
willing to work for it then we must work
like never before and we must once again
and stand
we can trust
keep moving this great country forward
Barack Obama
see
Oh